reading about your life which fascinates
me because I know at a very early age
you come from a very artistic family and
you come from a family that was very and
feels like open I mean you're living in
the are you living in a village where
are you living in SoHo kind of Loft yeah
my parents were were visual artists and
they moved to the Bowery in the late 60s
and then
um bought a loft building on Crosby
Street with another couple for literally
like negative like I mean just a
shocking stuff that makes people angry
today serious yes um I bought this house
for eleven hundred dollars murderous
yeah yeah um yeah but uh so yeah and I I
mean the factories were were shutting
down all around me and being transformed
into these artists Studios and you had
to actually legally prove that you were
an artist to live there at the time it
was
um but anyway so yes it was a funny way
to live and um and very permissive uh in
a lot of in a lot of ways but nobody you
know nobody around me was involved with
the perform forming arts and actually it
was only until I did that show Finding
Your Roots When I learned that my
paternal grandmother who I never knew
and actually died when my dad was 10 and
her name is Claire James
um named after like she apparently got a
masters in the role of dance and
Shakespearean drama and had acted and
directed and plays and
um and I was kind of stunned by that
because there was no indication of of
this being anywhere in the gene pool
yeah I don't I don't come from I come
from uh dad's a research scientist my
mom was a lawyer and then I go back
before that and my grandfather's a
policeman and my you know just you're I
look around and I keep thinking is there
where if I go back 200 years is there a
ventriloquist dummy
must be a picture somewhere of a guy
with like puffy hair who's making an
asset himself and being chased by angry
people
um but I heard that you early on you
were interested in mimicking is that
true yeah so my first memory of acting
was when I was in pre-nursary school and
I was must have been like three or four
yeah and slow was my teacher she was
Indian and I loved her and it was nap
time and I I was a terrible Napper I am
still a terrible Napper but I'm also you
know I was also like a totally
obsequious like people pleasing person
which I you know still on so anyway so I
wanted to convince her that I was
sleeping and I was doing my best
impression of a sleeping uh tiny child
and I I'd I'd remembered that my mom had
twitched in her sleep and so I was doing
this I was trying to do this twitch and
I thought oh yeah yeah that's good
that's really subtle that's super
nuanced she's never gonna know that I am
but that was the that was the feeling
that I was really working on the
verisamilitude you know
um and I do think that that's just
an innate impulse that we have and I I
don't know I think I was just always
really
really curious about the human
experience and wanting to you know kind
of make the most sense of it that I
could and just reflect on it yeah that's
uh it's it's interesting too that you
mentioned your parents and I would think
not even knowing them or knowing about
them I would give them credit for the
fact that you have your head on your
shoulders you've made such good
decisions and I think being
famous when you're 13 14 and I know even
at the time I've read quotes of yours
from the time 14 15 you're very
thoughtful about it and you're trying to
parse it and figure it out you're not
saying get me a stretch limo right uh
let's go three times around the park and
I I wanna no it was it was a very
intense transition into the world of
entertainment and we were all so naive
um you know I got this show myself I
mean I I knew that I wanted to explore
this acting thing my parents kind of
thought okay it's another after school
activity like piano or dance or whatever
it was and um and I just started kind of
hustling like I found this junior Arts
uh junior
um junior high school for performing
arts program and I went to Lee
Strasbourg and I went to HB Studios but
this was all my own
um
uh uh my by my own making and they
didn't interfere but you know and but
and they were generally supportive but I
would just rollerblade from audition to
audition you know I would like get some
jobs in that eventually materialized
into a career to all of our total
astonishment yeah and then we were on a
plane my brother is seven years older so
he was at College at this point and we
kind of had the the latitude to do that
uh my dad's business was he was a
contractor that was naturally ending and
um we were available to this experience
thank goodness like together as a unit
um but we were deposited in La it was
like the day after that massive
earthquake in 94. and so there were
actual aftershocks like the ground was
shaking which is just an absurd absurdly
apt metaphor and they were preparing for
you exactly at the time there were a lot
of seismologists at the time that said a
major Talent has landed in LA and we
think that's responsible it was a
bizarre correlation
um and yeah it took we were you know uh
bewildered and just kind of
attempting to not look like total idiots
you know for a few years
um but no I totally credit them with
um whatever kind of orientation I ended
up maintaining yeah and my mom was
always with me on set and you know they
were not stage parents in any way we
didn't even know how to like pretend you
know that that was well I was around it
because I was around stage parents
because we were routinely booking kids
to play you know we never used real
people on the show so whenever I brought
my mom out it was always a different
actress whenever I brought like yes yes
we always I made a point of making sure
that we had this kind of SCTV fake
Pee-wee's Playhouse version of reality
but you know my son would come on the
set when I didn't even have a son right
right and he'd have a little red
pompadour wig and so we were always
doing things like that so kids were
always around and
I so often remember them coming up to me
as if they'd been hit with cattle prods
and they would say Mr O'Brien I wish to
tell you that you have
transformed late night and you have made
a generational impact and had looked
behind them and see the parents staring
at them like we practiced this all night
it's this you go say to code
and I would feel comfortable yeah you
feel terrible about it
um they all went on to be very famous
um that was Ben Affleck anyway uh no I'm
kidding um that but but it was just
incredible that
uh I think it's the exception that
proves the rule and I think the fact
that you were very new you were
thoughtful and your parents are
thoughtful and then you decide I need to
get an education yeah well my parents
were always adamant that you know I be
tutored on set I mean that was a very
real priority and they didn't have to
impose that on me either like that was
something I wanted to
um uh remain involved with and then yeah
and I think I was I got a little I did
get a little dizzy and overwhelmed at a
certain point
um and was being given a lot of
opportunity and didn't quite know how to
channel that focus it you know and um
you know I didn't have a filter yet that
I kind of needed to establish yeah
um in a safer place like uh you know a
campus
um and I was a little lonely you know I
I mean initially I was so relieved to be
jettisoned out of the hell of junior
high and in high school was it was it a
hell yeah I think it was going to get
less hellish
um because I was I was moving through
high school and I think kids just get
increasingly more or less desperate and
cruel you're getting bullied yeah I had
a really hard time in Middle School
um what do you think that bullying was
about or do you remember there was a few
things I I mean I went to a few
different schools for funny reasons it's
not like I was always living in the same
place but you know I had a teacher that
my mom wasn't that thrilled by or I I
don't know there was there's always a
reason to to try out a different school
so I was often the new girl and sort of
conspicuous and a little targeted for
that reason but I also was just like
very sensitive to the injustices that
were often on display and and and
couldn't help but I don't know
um
kind of take the beat right and and
um I don't know it the the politics made
me insane the social politics
um and yeah so I think I had like
I wasn't strictly bullied but I was I
was vulnerable and I was also I really
liked learning you know I was nerdy and
kind of didn't get the memo that you're
supposed to pretend that you're not so
engaged and curious at a certain point
as a girl right um right so my hand
remained very like high in the air you
know
um uh and I yeah anyone but Claire
anyway answer this question there was
legit annoying too I mean I I think that
was fair yeah um but I don't know and um
yeah there was always like oh girl I
changed three I went to three different
junior high schools and there was the
same prototype archetype our typical
girl who was crazy smart and very
troubled and decided that I was somebody
that they were gonna you know make very
unhappy yeah um yeah and they just kept
like materializing I wish I had known
there's so many things you wish that you
knew
uh you could go back in time and tell
the younger you and I would just the one
thing I would tell the younger me is
when people are really mean to you or
bullying you it's because they're
miserable I think that would have helped
me somewhere I think I kind of knew that
but I didn't know that but it didn't I
didn't know it wasn't much of a tonic
yeah like you're still stuck and once
that once that Dynamic is in play you're
sort of screwed because you're just in a
cage like there's nowhere to go right
um and
um yeah like it's funny I've my son now
is 10 and so he's starting to enter that
point and he is he's such a wonderful
tender clever goofball like he's but and
I see all of his kind of vulnerability
and but
it's funny because a mom from the school
texted me about her son being aware of
some bullying that was happening in his
grade and but Cyrus is just sort of like
oblivious or or just not very moved by
it you know and and her son was you know
and and I was like oh gosh I I was your
son you know and I'm so grateful that my
son isn't you know like it's a kind of
amazing defense to just not really our
kids the notion that someone would not
be nice to them hurts more than anything
else oh my God it's brutal although I my
four-year-old son Rowan
like he could be a he could go the bully
route like I'm I'm always Got Talent
he's got yeah no but it's like I'm
terrified that my older son might be
bullied and I'm terrified that my
younger son might be the bully right and
so it's um it's good to have one of each
so people most people think that having
one of each means a boy and a girl it's
like no no I have a bully and I have
someone who is bullied yeah I've done it
both but I'm glad they were born in that
order because it would be really
problematic if it was reversed
um and I think we just worry you know
for what I you know it doesn't take much
to yeah yeah